the part that I enjoy most about uh C4
meetings is that it brings together a
very diverse um set of experts and you
really need this to map the human body
across
scales having a range of expertise
around the room to to talk about this
challenging problem that is incredible
you know intense discussion over two
days to find a way forward and you can't
solve this without that
interdisciplinary
approach this multiscale model has been
the holy GL of the system biology since
its Inception 25 years ago and I think
time is right you know we have a better
technology we have better understanding
how to go about it so this is really a
Grand Challenge or the moonshot for
biomedical science if you're able to um
accomplish mapping the human body across
scales then what might be possible is to
have a digital twin of you so when you
are born this algorithm would start
running and as data sets become
available you could run any kind of
predictions of what might happen over
your lifetime in that model and I think
it will help us understand why certain
diseases happen and how to treat them
better or even recognize them before
they start and so I look forward to more
Precision Health less
medicine we are on the very early stage
of yet another Industrial Revolution in
next 5 years we're going to see the
dramatic change in the way we do science
and I think this C Maan multiscale human
project can be really the Showcase
embracing new technology because you
need the technology to achieve the
science I think I'm just grateful that
you know CA and McMillan see this
challenge as being fundamentally
important in in terms of where we go
next in mapping the human body to really
make that transformative Next Step the
radical change that's needed to improve
human
[Music]
life